we're going to start this hour with the
war in Ukraine it began when Russia
troops invaded that country one year ago
tonight our time Russia and many
International observers expected that
this war would end in weeks or possibly
even days as you know that did not
happen instead Ukraine held on and they
fought back and they are still fighting
back and now the war is entering a
second bloody year it's hard to believe
Charlie dagada was in Ukraine's Capital
at the moment Russia's Invasion started
he's there again this morning to take a
look back at what happened
overnight the lives of millions of
people in Ukraine changed forever
big boom big boom we were on the balcony
of our safe house in Kiev at around 5
A.M
three to begin with
[Music]
when Russian President Vladimir Putin
announced the start of a special
military operation
moments later Thunders explosions Echo
throughout the capital
and more cities throughout the country
Europe's biggest Invasion since World
War II was underway
despite repeated warnings from the West
a full-scale invasion was Unthinkable
for the average Ukrainian so I was
shocked the mayor of Kiev Tali Klitschko
recalled setting his alarm for 3 A.M the
night before 3 o'clock three o'clock in
the morning because we have information
for Global starting Innovation I
received a call from military forces
from my friends
uh The Invasion started
National Security Chief Alexi danieloff
showed us official government data
charting the first wave of the invasion
the Russians were launching airstrikes
Across the Nation and ground offensives
on multiple fronts as Russian
paratroopers landed at the hospital
airfield on the outskirts of Kiev U.S
intelligence officials predicted the
capital itself would fall within 96
hours the main offensive was expected
from the East we understood that it
would be bottle for the donbass yes I
think that's what we were all expecting
yes but they started everywhere without
striking formation that's why they lose
ukrainians have criticized government
leaders for not warning the public that
the invasion was imminent they are
prepared but we tried to stop the panic
in our streets if we will be in a panic
regime people will be fleeing to the to
the border and it will be the obstacle
for our Armed Forces to move quickly
on those streets of Kiev President
Vladimir zielinski made it clear he was
staying put
in a Brazen Walkabout with members of
his captain
instead he urged citizens to take up
arms and they did by the thousands
weapons handed out to those who barely
knew how to use them hastily erected
barricades and checkpoints went up
everywhere manned by jittery volunteers
with guns drawn
day one of a war that still rages on for
CBS mornings Charlie dagada Kiev